Il s'appelait Matteo,
il se fait finalement arrêté
aps s s 30 ans de cavale.
- C'est la fin d'u D D D D D D ,
le fugitif le plus recherché
d'Italie, a été arrêté ce matin
dans une clinique médicale de
Palerme où il recevaitpopopopop.
Dernier chef présumé de la mafia
sicilienne, il avait réussi
à échapper à la police
pendant trois déce
"C'est un grand jour
ses dettes à ces martyrs
vieseses de la mafia", dit
le procureur en chef du pays.
"C'est une grande victoire, dit
la première ministre italie
à nos enfants qu'on peut battre
la mafia."
Giorgia Meloni est ensuite
allée se recueillir auu u u u ua
Giovanni Flacone, assassiné
par Denaro en 92.
C'est notamment pour ce meurtre,
ainsi que pour
à la bombe à Florence et à Rome,
que Messina Denaro avait été
condamné, en son absence,àààààà.
Il était en fuite depuis.
"La mafia, qui a mis l'Italie
dit cet habitant de Palerme.èèèt
symbolique en Italie. C'était
le dernier parrain activement
recherché après plusieurs
arrestations spectacéeéeéeéeéeé.
"La question qui se pose
maintenant, c'est : va-t-il ou ,
se demande ce professeur
de droit italien.
(sirènes)crcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcre
Denaro, affaibli par la maladie,
aurait pu être livré par
des proches. Il pourrait décider
en dévoilant les secrets
de l'organisation eeeeee
et en livrant ses complices.
Ici Lise Villeneuve